après tout ce temps tu viens me rendre
visite à mon frère
pourquoi pour me narguer
j'ai besoin de ton aide et j'aimerais
pouvoir te faire confiance
tu ne serait qu'un pauvre fou comme je
l' ai toujours cru
certains pensent qu avant l'univers il
n'y avait rien ils se trompent
et ils ont survécu
qu'est ce qui va nous arriver
je t'avais donné ma parole
reviendrait pour toi
peu d'entre nous savent
quel ennemi tu affrontes un seul le sait
tu dois être vraiment désespérée pour me
demander de l'aide
si nous ne faisons rien et nous anéantir
en dhr
si jamais tu trahis même en pense et je
te tuerais
ça c'est pour new york mais j'adore
courage n'atténuera pas ta souffrance
famille
deux seront réduits à néant
il faut grandir
le fils de la réalité sera rompu à
jamais
un moyen de tous nous sauver
à toi de jouer
au suivant